car prices are absolutely insane right
now this is for new cars and used cars
they keep climbing and climbing and
climbing it don't expect relief
anytime soon this is a cnbc story now
you guys don't need to take an economics
class to be familiar with the concept of
supply
and demand we got supply and we got
demand okay supply and demand so there's
a low supply of cars and there's a very
high demand for cars new and used okay
so apparently
regarding demand there's a low supply
demand there's about four to five
million
customers potential customers consumers
sitting on the sidelines waiting for
cars or waiting for cars prices to drop
okay so reasons for this not to get all
economics right now basically there's a
supply a supply chain crisis everything
ports have been shut down the world's
been shut down for the past two years so
people aren't working there's a lack of
workers right there's a labor shortage
and then there's something called
microchips or semiconductors that they
need to put in the cars and they put
into the cell phones they put everything
so there's a limit on that so basically
supply and demand there is you know high
demand people want cars people need to
move and there's low supply boom that's
your economics lesson right there
let's get into the numbers 90 of car
buyers are paying more
than the sticker price so here's an
example so for new cars the average
transaction price is higher than the
msrp the manufacturer suggested real
uh retail price i almost butchered that
one msrp so typically what does that
mean so if the msrp is 45 grand people
are paying 46 grand 47 grand because
usually going the line i guess it's 45
all right maybe you can knock something
off okay you can get it for 42. boom but
now people are paying more a little bit
more for new cars now when you get into
news cars think uh used cars thank you
for this um
thing right here so for used cars buyers
are paying an average of
29 000 for a used car now it is that is
up 28 from a year ago so for the average
used car a year ago just doing some
basic math if it went up 28
that means it was on average about 20
grand so now you go for a used car it's
19.99 now they're gonna hit you for
29.99 boom it's a 28 increase so
a couple more stats for you uh a year
ago before the pandemic right or or the
beginning of the pandemic it took about
50 days to sell a new car
from the lot okay you with me nets 50
days now the average time is between 10
and 17 days that is a record
low so basically we're here's where we
go here we got supply we got demand
demand is high people need cars uh
there's not enough cars people are
paying more for cars cars cars cars cars
and by the way cars are depreciating
assets you don't want to have to over
pay for cars because once you drive it
off the lot it loses about 20 percent of
value and then every year it loses about
10 percent so the point is this you may
not get the car that you want and if you
are you're gonna have to overpay for it
so ladies let's open this up for you
how important is for you
for you
to drive a nice car how important is
that for you
jenny from the block
i drive the same car i've had since high
school oh you said that so like adorably
right there what was that i love my car
so what kind of car is it i have a mini
cooper uh white mini cooper i saw you
circle in the parking lot over there
okay you love your car but that's a nice
guy it's a good female car mini cooper
now if a dude was driving like a mini
cooper is that that's nice you're
driving a mini cooper all that
so that is a female car just putting it
out there so for dudes out there driving
a mini cooper
step it up bro
yeah nancy how is important for you to
drive a nice car like for you
so i would have drove my car like i
would have just lasted for one car but i
literally drove my high school car into
the ground like i even got to the park
where
the door handle on the driver's side
broke off and i would go through the
passenger side for like six months i
gotta drive because i didn't want to
commit to buying a new car and then
eventually you're very thrifty though
yeah you're very thrifty you're cutting
coupons you're wheeling you're dealing
you're stealing you're doing what you
got to do
i've seen you you operate you're an
operator yeah yeah that's that that just
happened well so then when my car
finally did broke down um i ended up
buying like a honda a honda civic like
the most reliable car ever i bought it
for during like memorial day sale or
something sales sales
it had to be a sale and you had to be a
i'm telling you she's thrifty
and that's literally what i've been
driving for the past five years yeah and
as soon as that's like paid off i'm like
not i'm writing that to the ground too
[Music]
you